stable isotope labeling of amino acids
in cell culture otherwise popularly
known as psylac is a method used in
quantitative proteomics
this particular method uses metabolic
labeling technique
in this video we would learn the
principles of psylac and the
experimental workflow applications of
psylac and limitations of this technique
so stay tuned till the end of this video
let us begin with the experimental
workflow
in this case we have to culture cells in
two separate allicots and in one
allicode we have to grow them in a light
medium containing the amino acid lies
zero or Arginine zero so it's a light
version of these amino acids
so there are specific commercially
available media which has these
compositions
and on other side we have to grow some
cells equal number of cells most likely
using uh lysine 8 or Arginine 10 this
kind of heavy media
and later on we have to mix the cells in
one is to one proportion roughly about a
million of cells are required
then cells would be lysed using the
lysis buffer and from the cell lysate
proteins would be extracted
and those proteins would be eventually
trypsinized to create peptide fragments
now
trypsin always Cleaves at the c-terminus
of basic amino acids
so after trypsinization one would get
different fragments
so each of these fragments would be
either leveled with heavy Arginine or
light Arginine so each of these fragment
would be tagged you can imagine it like
a barcode and it could be detected by in
in the mass spectrometry
so ultimately these things would be
separated and in an lcms system and in
the mass spectrometry the mass by charge
ratio would be determined if you don't
know how Mass spectrometry work you can
quickly click on the I button to know
more about it anyway from the mass
spectrometry result these two samples
either heavily labeled amino acids or
lightly labeled amino acids can be
distinguished based on their
molecular weight because
M by Z ratio would be different for two
different samples and this is how they
can be distinguished so clearly
we can separate these things in a mass
spectrometry analysis
from those that was only for one gene
one particular protein now for many
proteins we can get a big picture about
the proteome we can perform
differentially and differential
enrichment analysis where we would
understand how many proteins are
enriched how many proteins are reduced
in quantity Etc also pathway analysis
can be performed that can tells us that
differentially regulated proteins
Falls in which particular pathway based
on known information in an bioinformatic
database
let us take some applications so let's
say you have two samples in one sample
you have treated with drug X and vehicle
and other sample is only treated with
vehicle and imagine the vehicle treated
sample is grown in a light medium and
the drug treated sample is grown in a
heavy medium then the psylock method can
be performed to understand whether there
is a change in the proteome
after the treatment of drug X so we can
ask questions like which proteins are
over represented or upregulated and
which pathways are actually changing
so this would give us an idea about the
over overall proteum change under the
treatment of drug X now forget about
drug treatment think about some
developmental time point of a cell so
let's say a cell is transitioning
between three states so there is a Time
t 0 there is a Time T1 and there is a
Time T2 and you want to understand how
protein turnover is uh working right so
how several proteins are getting
created produced and degraded in these
particular time frame so one can take
out samples from each of these time
frames
note that
the time t 0
in the time t 0 you label it with
Arginine zero later on it is washed out
and now labeled with T1 now labeled with
Arginine eight and eventually it would
be again washed out and labeled with
Arginine 16. so in three different
stages we have three different uh
molecular weight and that's that can be
quickly distinguished in the mass
spectrometry analysis that means we can
ask the question how the full change of
these proteins vary over time
maybe one particular protein is
upregulated there are there are stable
maintenance of some protein levels there
are also down regulation of proteins all
these kind of analysis can be performed
using scilac so in addition to peptide
identification it gives us a quantity
quantitative measure and a temporal
kinetics in this data
so pros of psylac are plenty
so this is a very quantitative method
highly accurate
second multiplexing is possible so
multiple samples could be processed at
the same time and is extremely flexible
can be adopted for various system and
cell types
there are several cons obviously this
technique is sophisticated but expensive
sometimes labeling is incomplete and
this particular in order to perform this
technique you need specific knowledge in
terms of software and data analysis so
it's not a very straightforward
technique but very efficient technique
so I hope you get an overview of this
technique
if you need more notes and flashcards
you can visit my Facebook page or
Instagram page all the links are
provided in the description
you can support our channel in patreon
or you can help us by super thanks
option which is present in the bottom of
every video you can support us via paytm
PayPal or UPI see you in next video